[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen sallys welt
bei uns ist ja schon ein bisschen länger
weihnachten hinter küche zumindest weil
wir einfach schon viele videos für euch
gedreht haben aber mit diesem video
leiten wird heute oder läuten wir heute
die weihnachtssaison ein denn es wird
endlich weihnachtlich winterlich war und
kuschelig und wir starten heute mit dem
berliner rezept ich habe vor vielen
jahren schon mal berliner gemacht es ist
wirklich schon sieben jahre her ihr
könnt euch gern mal anschauen von ihrer
mutter noch kommt ganz klein und hat mir
mitgeholfen und heute habe ich mir
gedacht machen über berlin zum einen
weil wir einfach mal wieder raus
frittieren wollen
und zum anderen weil berlin nicht nur
standardmäßig gut schmecken sondern auch
zur weihnachtszeit und wir werden sie
später mit einer leckeren creme büffeln
und das wird glaube ich der oberhammer
und die anderen weihnachts videos die
kommen jetzt dann zusätzlich einfach
noch auf einen lieben youtube kanal und
bei inter sparte habe ich nämlich auch
schon einige von euch vorbereitet ich
mache jetzt erstmal den hefeteig der
besteht aus einem würfel hefe 40 gramm
zucker 2 esslöffel wasser etwas vanille
extrakt 250 milliliter milch einen
teelöffel salz 500 gramm mehl da könnt
ihr weizen oder dinkelmehl verwenden und
50 gramm weiche butter das war es schon
und jetzt nehmt ihr einfach die hefe
größte innen der schlüssel ihr könnt den
teig natürlich jederzeit mit den händen
verkneten oder auch ein handrührgerät am
anfang nehmen hauptsache er wird später
einfach schön lange geknetet hefe und
zucker sind schon hier drin wasser gebe
ich dazu frühere zutaten kurz
[Musik]
dann gebe ich hier noch vanille extrakt
dazu das könnt ihr generell eigentlich
bei hefeteig immer dazu geben dann habt
ihr da schon direkt einen vanille
geschmack und jetzt fühle ich die
anderen zutaten hinzu
milch und 1 1 bevor das salz kommt aber
erst mal das mehl denn das salz gebt ihr
am besten immer erst dazu wenn das meer
schon dabei ist damit das alles nicht
direkt an die hefe kommt das mag die
nicht so sehr
und die butter dann auch zum schluss
einfach oben drauf
und schön ein kneten und ihr seht schon
ich habe ein bisschen mehr übrig
gelassen denn je nach milchsorte kann es
sein dass wir mal ein bisschen mehr oder
weniger verwenden müsst die milch gebe
ich aber noch komplett dazu und das
schätze ich dann immer nach so 23
minuten gehzeit ab wenn der teig dann
nämlich noch zu weich ist gebe ich noch
das mehl dazu ansonsten lasse es einfach
weg er sitzt noch ein bisschen viel aber
am ende kann sein dass er so 40 bis 50
gramm mehr oder weniger braucht kommt
auch immer darauf an wie groß das ist
was man verwendet und wie viel
flüssigkeit das mehl eben auch aufnimmt
nicht gäbe jetzt hier bei der canon wird
einfach direkt noch jetzt damit dazu
stufe 2 und fertig
[Musik]
jetzt ist der hefeteig fertig ich habe
bei mir jetzt das gesamte mail gebraucht
und ihr seht wenn man den so zehn
minuten knetet wird er einfach schön
geschmeidig schön glatt klebt nicht mehr
und jetzt freue mich den einfach schön
zu einer kugel
fertig kann die schüssel noch kurz
einfetten
die teig kugel einfetten und den teig
dann abgedeckt für etwa eine stunde
ruhen lassen bis es sich verdoppelt hat
oder ihr könnt den kennwort eingeben mit
hitze 32 grad ungefähr 32 bis 34 grad
ungefähr und könnte ihn darauf gehen
lassen oder auch ganz gerne falls ihren
dampf backofen besitzt bei der stufe 34
grad dauert das ganze nur 30 minuten und
ich werde es in der zwischenzeit auch
schon mal eine creme herstellen die
creme dich da ein fühlen werde und
entweder könnte die creme auf dem herd
kochen oder auch hinter kenwood falls
ihr eine habt einfach bei 90 grad alles
vorher kurz schön glatt verrühren denn
dann bremst der pudding nicht an das ist
immer ganz praktisch ich mache jetzt
hier jetzt sind creme da hab ich mich
jetzt dafür entschieden ich glaube das
passt ganz gut und vor allem markt der
murat zimt eis ganz gerne und deswegen
denke ich mal keine zimt füllung in
berlin an ganz gerne für die zimt creme
nämlich 300 gramm milch 50 gramm sahne 3
eigelb 70 gramm zucker einen teelöffel
zimt und 25 gramm stärke gehen ein
bisschen milch in den topf
dann die eigelbe dazu
die stärke mit rein und dann schon mal
klümpchen frei verrühren und es geht
immer ganz gut mit etwas weniger milch
statt direkt mit der vollen portion
bin jetzt nicht alle klümpchen
verschwinden ist nicht schlimm das
kriegen wir gleich auch mit musik und
jetzt einfach die übrigen zutaten
dazugeben
auch die sahne
sind und zucker
und dann kann ich jetzt hier bei
ständigem rühren und etwa mittlerer
hitze als ich mache immer gerne auf
stufe sieben oder acht den pudding diese
creme eindecken lassen also sie darf
schon gerne einmal aufkochen das dauert
ist ein paar minuten
nicht anbrennen lassen
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich hier eine richtig schöne
cremige masse die fülle ich jetzt direkt
um die ecke ab und lasse abkühlen und
waadt einfach nur noch drauf bis der
hefeteig aufgeht
[Musik]
direkt an der oberfläche und abkühlen
lassen
jetzt ist der teig gut aufgegangen und
den nehme ich jetzt hier raus der ist
richtig schön ich habe ja auch etwas
weniger zucker drin als in meinen
standard hefeteig rezepten denn der wird
ja auch später noch gefüllt und da kommt
noch zucker obendrauf und der zucker
bewegt auch dass es im fett ein bisschen
dunkler wird und ich möchte recht helle
berliner haben deswegen diesem weniger
zu kommen
ach ist das ein schöner tag und
ich hatte den damals war ich noch in
zwölf portionen eingeteilt und kügelchen
geformt und dann frittiert ich mache
jetzt aber so dass ich es ausstechen
werde das heißt ein bisschen mehl und
dann gleichmäßig dünn ausrollen und ich
nehme jetzt hier einfach meinen ausrollt
starb dann habt ihr diese zehn
millimeter also ein zentimeter ringe
dann ist er einfach schön gleichmäßig
dick
könnte aber auch holzstäbe verwenden die
einen zentimeter dick sind oder einfach
versuchen so gleichmäßig wie möglich
auszurollen
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt doch die acht millimeter
ringe benutzt ist ich glaube ein
zentimeter ist doch ein bisschen zu dick
tatsächlich machen diese 2 mm doch ganz
schön viel aus der teig sieht sich auch
immer mal so ein bisschen zusammen dann
habe ich das jetzt hier und
jetzt könnt ihr euch ein glas nehmen und
becher oder auch ausstecher wenn ihr
glaubt unschöne kreise ausstechen nicht
so groß tatsächlich denn die berliner
gehen ja im heißen fett auch noch auf
und ich lasse auch jetzt gleich noch
aufgehen das heißt ich glaube ich nehme
jetzt hier einmal die
größe
ich glaube ich mache jetzt einfach ein
paar kleinere und ein paar größere
wir können uns nicht entscheiden
jutta und york sind für die kleineren
und tolga nicht wird die größe sind
wir gucken einfach
die last jetzt hier nochmal abgedeckt
legen damit sie noch mal ein bisschen
aufgehen können in der zeit werde ich
aber auch schon mal das frittierfett
aufheizen auf etwa 160 170 grad ich
werde das jetzt gleich in der friteuse
machen oder ihr könnt das ganze auch
natürlich auf dem herd machen in einem
großen topf oder in einer großen pfanne
das geht auch und den restlichen teig
hier den befreit ihr am besten vom
übrigen mail also schön abklopfen
zusammengenähten noch einmal aufgehen
lassen und dann einfach den vorgang noch
mal wiederholen aber der ist jetzt
einfach zu zäh da muss jetzt einfach
noch ein bisschen ruhe damit dass sich
wieder schön ausrollen lässt und dann
kann man auch einfach weiter verarbeiten
ich habe zu meinen frittierfett drin
und habe es auch schon aufgeheizt falls
ihr das ganze in der pfanne oder in den
topf macht könnte jetzt ein holzstäbchen
nehmen und mit dem holzstäbchen die
temperatur checken also einfach rein
halten und wenn es gleich anfängt zu
blubbern ist es auf jeden fall heißt ihr
solltet das feld aber nicht überhitzen
also wirklich zwischen 160 170 grad ist
perfekt dann habe ich hier noch eine
schüssel voll zucker da kommt ein
teelöffel zimt dazu doch
wir machen zwei
ein probe welchen da habe ich jetzt so
ein kleines stückchen übrig
jetzt werden hier die berliner
reingelegt am besten nicht so viele auf
einmal weil das fett dann zu sehr
abgekühlt und dann scheint es auch auf
solltet ihr auf keinen fall machen jetzt
schön vorsichtig einer schaumkelle zum
beispiel reinlegen ins bett legen und
dann von beiden seiten auspacken
drews einmal direkt auch um
perfekt dann gehen so schön gleichmäßig
auch auf
und je nachdem wie groß ist ihr habt
dauert es jetzt etwa drei bis vier
minuten auf jeder seite
also rein legen dann einmal um flippen
die erste seite anpacken dann wieder
drehen und dann die zweite seite bis sie
schön goldbraun sind
und dunstabzug an
aber heute ist bei uns mit ihr tag
deswegen darf nicht stinken aber ich
mach doch mit dem dumpfen zugang
besser
[Musik]
nachdem frittieren lege ich die fertigen
berliner erst mal ganz kurz auf
küchenpapier damit das fett so ein
bisschen abtropfen kann und welche sie
dann ins im zucker und am besten macht
ihr so dass er erst die oberseite ein
taucht dann die unterseite dann bleibt
nämlich der schöne weiße rand auch frei
jetzt habe ich alle gebacken und es ist
noch ein bisschen abgekühlt die cremes
jetzt noch leicht lauwarm aber das ist
okay falls ihr kleine klümpchen habt
dann solltet ihr sie jetzt durch ein
sieb streichen am besten damit die
klümpchen weg sind und jetzt habe ich
hier eine fülle dran die extra für
krapfen bzw berliner gemacht ich sehe
jetzt auch die creme hat eine relativ
weiche konsistenz falls sie zu fest
geworden ist könnt ihr noch einen
schluck sahen oder milch dazugeben denn
ansonsten bekommt ihr sie nicht durch
die spritze durch mit dann ein bisschen
schwierig
und jetzt vielleicht als tipp nehmt euch
eine vage setzten den berliner drauf
drückt auf null denn dann seht ihr auch
wie viel füllung reinkommt ansonsten ist
es immer so eine sonne augenmaß sache
bzw gar kein augenmaß mal was ganz sieht
aber so könnt ihr ein bisschen
kontrollieren ob wirklich was reingeht
[Musik]
generell
will ich sonst vorher nicht rein
und es echt gut wenn die creme noch
leicht lauwarmes da geht es ein bisschen
einfacher jetzt das gut
und schön in die mitte soweit es geht
ich finde es gibt nichts schlimmeres als
berliner die nur am rand die füllung
haben ich will dir immer in der mitte
also die füllung wird jetzt auch auf
jeden fall ausreichen für alle berliner
aber ich weiß ich habe hier auch einige
frucht fans deswegen fühle ich jetzt die
hälfte mit der zimt cream und die andere
hälfte mit pflaumenmus weil es auch sehr
gut dazu passt
[Musik]
ok jetzt bin ich fertig ich muss sagen
dass berlin abaco das geht noch also
nicht halt so ein bisschen im haushalt
nach frittierfett muss man schon dazu
sagen wobei man ja auch draußen auf der
terrasse frittieren könnte wenn man
möchte aber so dass füllen an sich ist
schon eine kleine sauerei also bis man
da mal die füllung drin hat und alles ja
aber es schmeckt lecker ich das ist halt
machte jutta probieren
was macht dich also ich würde ja gerne
beide probiere hast du aber nicht in
gang gehalten
hat muss noch da vorne haben gesagt wer
ist denn schon einen ganzen und dann
dastehen wird der kamera so
ich finde der berliner perfekt wenn sie
diesen weißen rand haben
und nach schön wäre ja schön gebräunt
genau
füllung in der mitte
ich finde es auch schön wenn man es so
anrichtet dass man auch die füllung
sieht ja dann weiß man auch was man
kriegt und was man ist ja so
schön luftig kam mir probieren ja ich
probiere ich mal cremig und ich finde
auch uns im zucker lacht mir jetzt so
ansgar haase sogar
schon mal gut mit krimi so gibt es beim
bäcker berliner nur im spätjahr
und nicht über sommer
das ist die frage
immer zum bäcker geht im hochsommer gibt
keine berlin
vielleicht ist mal weniger frittiertes
im hoch noch
mal zu spät ist der jetta war
vielleicht schon
da war schon auffällig muss man sagen ja
berliner aus dem ofen sind übrigens ein
fachbuch
traten als wir geplant haben dass wir
sehr schöner machen
wurde das ganze erst rate ich nicht
abgestimmt
da war stark
und alles erlebt
muss man natürlich man muss prioritäten
setzen ja ich nicht
weil
man als langhaar frau
wenn man seine haare pflegen möchte die
kann man nicht jeden tag war schon das
tut der kopfhaut ja und dann werde ich
muss er halt nur ein bis zweimal die
woche und dann ist schon wichtig wenn
ich jetzt heute morgen die haare
gewaschen hätte und ich hab heute
frittiert anderes geht machen muss man
ja heute zweimal war schon heute morgen
und heute ja ich hab sie früher auch
jeden tag aber erstens aber leider fand
und zweitens pflege ist nicht gut für
die kopfhaut und auch nicht für die
längen um spitzen deswegen falls ihr
euch demnächst
kennt ihr ja ich habe eine
mutter macht es immer lustig über uns
lang auf
ja wenn bei euch der sahara stark an
steht und wir frittieren wollt dann und
und kündigt auch immer an weil bei sarah
ist nämlich genauso wenn dann was
anbraten was zubereitet und ich habe mir
vorher nicht sagt ja schlacht schon
verdreht wie immer durch steckt sieht ja
irgendwo in den polieren oder indirekt
über eine tüte drauf keine ahnung ob das
stimmt
beide haben ihr inhaber starker winde
abgebrochen
das war halt so
damit man bearbeitet
also first things first
die wichtigsten dinge
das essen
nach dem horror stark und dann wenn ihr
die berliner ausprobiert könnt ihr immer
schreiben ob mit oder ohne füllung und
ob ihr team fruchtig seit oder cremig
als ich hatte jetzt den fruchtigen noch
nett aber
ganz außer halbieren oder so beides so
rein spritzen aber die vielzahl wechsel
aber ich find man kann es machen aber
ich muss sagen berliner dass ich so ein
ding bei mir das kaufe ich dann halt
ja
mag es eigentlich mit zur kristallzucker
oder mit puderzucker eigentlich liebe
mit 60 mann das mit kristallzucker dass
der server drauf
also will ich mag es bei machen
das rezept findet ihr in meiner app oder
auf meinem blog auf salehs blog.de ich
mach's gut und bis zum nächsten wahl
sind könnt ihr bitte schreiben wir ja
ohne haarspray gehabt bitte
jeden morgen
wie recht
nicht durch jeden tag zurück
[Musik]